JON JAKLITSCH:
I'm Jon Jaklitsch,
I'm gonna be your host.
In today's Talks
at Google session,
we're very excited to
welcome pro footballer
and current head coach of
New York City FC-- everyone
please give a warm welcome
to Mr. Patrick Vieira.
[APPLAUSE]
Pleasure to have you.
Patrick, welcome to Google.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
I was quite really
excited to come
to Google-- a little bit
less now, because I seen too
many Red Bulls shirts.
[LAUGHTER]
But the good thing is that
they are sitting at the back.
So it's OK.
[LAUGHTER]
JON JAKLITSCH: So
Patrick, I think
there's a lot of interest
here about your playing career
and also about your
transition to being a manager.
But I thought we'd start off
to talk about your early years.
Can you tell us, how did
you first get into football?
PATRICK VIEIRA: Football
always been part of my life
since I was seven,
eight years old.
I grew up in Senegal.
And from Senegal,
we moved to Paris
when I was eight,
nine years old.
And honestly, football
was and still a easy way
to get out of poverty.
And growing up with cousins,
uncles, brothers, life
wasn't that simple.
But we always managed
to get what we needed.
And growing up, find out that I
had a small talent in football.
And I was more concentrate
on the sports side
than on the academic side of it.
And I wanted to use a talent
to really do something
really interesting, and
something that I love,
and something that will help my
family to have a better life.
And I was quite, quite lucky.
Because every year that I was
involved in the football club,
I always had somebody to support
me, somebody to guide me,
to make me realize how important
it is, to make a sacrifice.
And those peoples really
contribute massively
on who I am today.
JON JAKLITSCH: Can you tell
us more about your role models
growing up?
PATRICK VIEIRA: But when I
grew up in France in '84,
you had a really
successful national team.
We used to call them
the [SPEAKING FRENCH].
I think the French people
who are in the room
will know who I
am talking about.
We had the players like
Platini, Tigana, Alain Giresse,
and Luis Fernandez.
There were the heart of
the French National Team
at that period.
And Luis Fernandez, who
was an example for me,
because he was playing
in the same position.
And he was an idol.
He was somebody that
I was looking up.
And I was really lucky,
because I had him
as a manager when
I was in Cannes.
And he was the coach that
made me play my first game
in the professional level.
JON JAKLITSCH:
That's great, Patrick.
Switching now into your
professional career,
you've had a lot of great
achievements in your career.
What would you
rank, looking back,
as the one you're most proud of?
PATRICK VIEIRA: I've
been really lucky,
because I achieve more than
what I was dreaming of.
And I've been really
successful, because I
was at the right place
at the right time.
I make the right decision
at the right time,
because when I was 17, the
club that I was playing for
went into a bankrupt.
And when the club's
going into a bankrupt
we became a free agent, so
I had different options.
And I was really lucky to
make the right choices.
Because that choices
helped me to grow up,
and to improve myself,
and to be a better player.
But you know, what is
important is that football
was and still a big passion.
And I fell in love
with the game.
And even today, it is a passion.
And it is a love for the game.
But to answer your
question that I forget--
[LAUGHTER]
JON JAKLITSCH:
So accomplishment
that you're most proud
of in your career?
PATRICK VIEIRA:
But you know what?
Winning the World Cup in '98
with the French National Team
is a big, big achievement.
Because we won the
World Cup in France.
And at that time,
France was going
through a really
difficult period
of crisis-- identity, racism.
So to win the World
Cup, I think we
send a really strong message.
Because that period,
the French National Team
had a massive reflect
on the society.
The diversity of the
French national team
was the French society.
So it was really strong message
that we sent to the world.
And that was a really
proud moment for me
to be part of that team.
And of course, signing my
first professional contract
was a massive
success, because that
is what I was dreaming about
since I was eight years old.
And of course, going
through with Arsenal
through a season unbeaten
was a good achievement.
And being coach as well, because
during my playing career,
being a coach wasn't
part of my plan.
If you was asking
me, do you want
to be a coach when you retired,
I would said, no chance.
[LAUGHTER]
And just life is
full of surprising.
JON JAKLITSCH: Tell me
more about the World Cup
when you won in France in '98.
What do you remember most
about what happened afterwards?
How did it change your life?
PATRICK VIEIRA: It
changed my life,
because that put me there
with the rest of the players
in the international level.
Winning the World Cup
WITH the team that we had
was unbelievable.
I don't think the
French National Team
will have the team that we had.
Because that team
was unbelievable.
We had the best player in
the world of Zinedine Zidane.
We had one of the
best goalkeeper
at the time with Fabien Barthez.
We had one of the best
defender in the world
with Marcel Desailly, the best
outside back with Lizarazu
and Lilliam Thuram.
And just those player
was unbelievable.
And that time, we
had everything.
We had talent.
We had experience.
We had desire to compete.
Everything was there
to win the World Cup.
And to do it in France was
a fantastic achievement.
JON JAKLITSCH: That's great.
That's great.
And you talked a little bit
about your unbeaten season
at Arsenal.
Looking back on that
season, is there
any particular moment
you remember most
from that season, maybe a time
where you thought, you know,
oh, this is the end, it's
not gonna to happen anymore,
or this was my favorite
moment from that season?
PATRICK VIEIRA: It's really
difficult to pick up a moment.
But what I would
during the season
is that we knew
that was our moment.
Because every time we went
through a difficult period,
it was somebody was doing
something different.
It was Dennis Bergkamp
was doing something
that was unbelievable.
It was Thierry Henry was going
to score the goal by himself.
It was Robert Pires
was making a good play.
It was the goal keeper was
making an unbelievable save.
We was going losing
two-nil at half time.
And we will manage to get back,
because we had the spirit.
We had the quality up
front to score the goal,
so not to concede the goal.
But I think that generation
was really complete,
because in every line,
we had leadership.
We had talent.
And we had, for me, what
was really important,
the same goal, the common goal.
JON JAKLITSCH: Mm.
PATRICK VIEIRA: And
that was fantastic.
And of course, the
relationship between us
as well was really good.
It's a really special moment.
That's what I was saying early
on that I was quite really
lucky.
Because I really play for teams
where we had talents, yes,
but where we really live
together really well.
Because to achieve, or to
win something, or to do well,
you need more than a talent.
And at Arsenal, at
Juventus, or even
with the French National Team,
we had more than the talent.
And this is the reason why
we have been successful.
JON JAKLITSCH: I've heard
you talk a lot about what
makes a great team.
I've heard you say that it's not
necessarily having, you know,
a great player and
then not caring
about let's say the goalkeeper
or the defenders, right?
It's having balance
within a team.
Would you say that
was something that
was very common in the
best teams that you played?
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yes, yes.
It was really common.
Because what was
really important for us
is to understand what
is your strength,
and what can you do
to help the team?
Like myself, if I was trying
to be Zinedine Zidane,
we never going to
win the World Cup.
[LAUGHTER]
If you build a team to
have 11 Zinedine Zidane,
you're will not going
to win the World Cup.
I think you will need to
mix the team regarding
the quality of the players and
what the teams really need.
And it's important for
players to identify themself,
to know themself, and to
know what is their role
and the responsibility
on the field.
And when you have a talent
in the team and everybody
respecting each other,
then you have more time
to succeed and to be successful.
And the French National
Team, that's was a strength.
At Arsenal, that
was our strength.
Thierry Henry knew
that his strength
was to score the goals.
His strength was to run
behind the back four.
Zidane was the mind of our team.
He was the creative players.
You have architect.
And you have builders.
So when the builders
try to be the architect,
we're having a problem.
And I think in every kind
of business, it's the same.
And at Arsenal at the time, if
I was try to be the architect,
then it will be a problem.
JON JAKLITSCH: We talked
about this a little
before we came on stage.
But you were actually very
excited to come to Google
to learn how we work
together and how
we build great teams,
which is something
I thought was very interesting.
Do you want to maybe talk
a little bit about that?
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yeah, I find
it quite really interesting,
because you are
international brand.
And I think you have
people who are coming
from all around the world.
And it's quite
really interesting
to see how you put in
this kind of differences
together to be
really successful.
And when you look at in a
dressing room in our world,
in football, it's
quite the same.
Because we have players
coming all around
the world, different background.
But the objective
still the same--
how can we put our difference
on the side but working together
to be successful?
And what I find quite
really interesting
is that when we came
inside the building,
I find it quite really fresh.
[LAUGHTER]
There's colors everywhere.
And I think what make it
really successful brand
is the fact that when you
come in in the building,
you want to stay
in the building.
You want to work
It's a good place to be.
I know that the food is free.
That's one of the reasons.
[LAUGHTER]
JON JAKLITSCH: I don't
know if you've heard.
But we're hiring if
you want to work here.
[LAUGHTER]
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yeah.
But it's true.
It is really nice
place to spend time.
Because you spend more time here
than at home with your family.
And that is what we need
to create in our world,
in football is we want
players to come and spend
time in our office-- in
the office, you can say.
We want players
to come and spend
time in the training ground.
So it's important for us to
make it nice, to make it really,
really nice to spend time.
And I find it-- I do
understand one of the reason
that you guys been
really successful.
And I think that is quite
really interesting for us
to take back to our world.
JON JAKLITSCH: And we hope
you can get some ideas when
we do the tour.
Have that later.
Thanks.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yes.
JON JAKLITSCH: Changing
subjects a little bit,
still talking about
your playing career now,
you've had the chance to captain
a few teams in your career.
Tell me what it takes
to be a good captain.
PATRICK VIEIRA: I
think it's always
the same question is are
you born as a leader,
or you become a leader?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PATRICK VIEIRA: Huh?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK VIEIRA: You
become a leader?
I don't agree.
[LAUGHTER]
But that is what is
interesting is that we
have a different point of view.
But with my experience is that
I believe that in football,
to be successful, everybody
has to take leadership.
We need 11 leader on the
field to be successful.
And it was quite funny.
Because when I was spending
time in Manchester City,
people will say that Mario
Balotelli is not a leader.
[LAUGHTER]
But I disagree.
I think he's a leader--
in a different way--
[LAUGHTER]
--but he's still a leader.
Just to give you an
example, we were playing
the game against Tottenham.
And we was losing two-nil.
And we managed to
get back to the game.
It was a two-two.
And it was a last
minute penalty.
To take that responsibility,
the last kick off the game,
to take that responsibility,k
you have to be--
--you understand?
Your mind has to be a bit crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's part of being a leader.
And for me, him taking the
ball in front of Sergio Aguero,
put it, and then
scored the goal is
for me is a sign of leadership.
And then after,
you have this type
of leader, what, like
Tony Adams at Arsenal.
He was really vocal,
really strong.
They didn't stop talking.
And he was a proper leader.
And I was a different
type of leader.
I was more leading by example.
The way that I will
conduct myself on the field
wasn't really vocal,
but I was tackling.
I was running.
I was-- that is a different
type of leadership.
So that's why I
believe that we all
have a little bit of
leadership in ourself.
And it's important
in any things that we
are doing to show that
we are quite strong.
JON JAKLITSCH: Did you
feel throughout your career
that you ever had to adjust
your leadership style
to match the people
you were working with?
PATRICK VIEIRA: Um--
JON JAKLITSCH: Or do
you feel the team kind
of morphed more around the
captain and the leader?
PATRICK VIEIRA: I
think as a captain,
I was always tried
to be a positive.
And it was important for me
was that, yes, I was a captain,
but it doesn't give
me the right to make
all the decision by myself.
When I was at Arsenal, I was--
Dennis Bergkamp, Martin Keown,
[INAUDIBLE], Seaman, or--
before making any decision,
I was talking to them, because
it was a team decision.
So they was really part of the
decision that I was making.
Being a captain doesn't
give you the right
to make the decision
by yourself.
You have responsibility, but one
of the biggest responsibility
is to bring everybody together.
So making a decision
with other players
I think give them a little
bit of captaincy as well.
So it was important for
me to make them understand
that captain is
just the hand band
that you're putting
around your hand.
But the team is more important
than just a captain on himself.
JON JAKLITSCH: Great, great.
Now sticking with the concept of
teammates, I'm curious to know,
throughout your career, who do
you think the best player you
played with throughout
your career--
and I'm putting you on the
spot a little bit, I know.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yeah.
But just to be
diplomat, I will say it.
What do you think
a good player is?
[LAUGHTER]
JON JAKLITSCH: Ooh, I'm
getting interviewed here.
PATRICK VIEIRA: I'm just going
to test him a little bit.
JON JAKLITSCH: I'm
going to change it back.
I think it's someone who
listens to their captain.
No--
[LAUGHTER]
I think-- and relating
this back to Google
and what I think
we've seen internally,
I think it's ability to
listen to your teammates,
understand maybe what
some of their strengths
are, what some of
their weaknesses are,
and kind of play
into that, not trying
to be someone else
that you're not,
and sticking with your
core strengths as a person.
But I think treating the
team above the individual
is what I would say.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yeah.
And completely,
I agree with you.
And this is why when
people asking me that
question, two names always up.
One is Zinedine Zidane and the
other one is Dennis Bergkamp.
And the reasons being
every single players
who played around those
players has been fantastic.
What I like about
both of them is
that they're making the
people around look good.
And for me, this is a sign
of a top class player.
There's a lot of good
players, but there's just
a little bit of top players.
And for me, Zidane with
the French National Team--
you can tell them-- Henri,
Berg-- Anelka, [INAUDIBLE],
Dugarry.
All those players who
played around Zidane
expressed themselves
really well.
And the same at Arnsenal--
Bergkamp played with Henri,
played with Anelka,
Overmars, Pires.
All those players look
really good because Bergkamp
makes them look really good.
So for me, this is a
sign of special players.
JON JAKLITSCH: Now how
about the best player
you think you played
against in your career?
PATRICK VIEIRA: Against?
I would say Roy
Keane from-- yes.
JON JAKLITSCH: I thought
that would come out.
PATRICK VIEIRA: I would say Roy
Keane because-- because it's
funny because we are sharing
the same type of vision
of the game, of leadership.
He has a really strong
mind, he's a fighter,
he's a team player, and
he likes to compete,
and he, as well, has a
psychology mind that he
likes to use in the game.
That, I quite like as well.
So we are quite similar.
And to be honest, every time
we play against each other,
it was tough, it was
really difficult,
and that's why I have a
massive respect for him
because he's been
a fantastic player.
JON JAKLITSCH: Great.
Now let's switch over to
your managerial career now.
You mentioned that if we asked
you, when you were younger,
you would have said, no way
would I ever be a manager.
So why now?
And, I guess, what changed
since you were younger?
PATRICK VIEIRA: I think
because I never put myself
on the other the side.
When I stopped playing
for Manchester City,
I didn't really
know what I really
wanted to do because I had been
playing football, and focused,
and concentrating about
football for 15 to 17 years.
So when I decided to stop,
it was really difficult
for me to find my
way, I would say.
So I was really lucky
because at Manchester City,
there was one of the directors,
called Brian Marwood.
And Brian had a vision
of me that I even
didn't have for myself.
So that's why it's
really important
to believe and to
listen to people
because sometimes people can
come with a really good idea.
So Brian offered me
to spend two years
in the staff in Manchester
City and to spend time
in different departments
in the football club.
I knew that I wanted to
stay involved in football
because this is what I love,
and this is what I know,
and this is what I do best.
But in which department?
I really didn't know at all.
So I spent time in the Academy,
I spent time in the finance,
I spent time with the
sporting director,
I spent time in recruitment,
in the community.
I tried to understand where
I can feel comfortable
or where I can
bring my experience.
And sitting in the
office wasn't something
that I was feeling
really comfortable with.
And when I spent time
in the Academy, the fact
that spending time with
the young players--
the way they were looking at
me, the way they were taking
into consideration the
message I was sending to them,
I felt really
comfortable about it.
At the same time, I
was doing my badges.
And I just fell in love because
I put myself in a situation
that I never been before.
And doing that allowed me
to know more about myself
and I felt in love
with coaching.
And I did my badges, and I
worked for two and half years
with the under 21 in
Manchester City, and I love it.
JON JAKLITSCH: That's great.
That's great.
And you've had a
chance, obviously,
to play for a lot of great
managers over the years.
Is there anyone in
particular that you feel
like has influenced you most?
Or do you think it's
a bit from each one?
PATRICK VIEIRA: All of them.
All of them because
I've been really lucky.
I had some of the best
managers in the world.
And I spent time with them,
I've been listening to them,
and, of course, I'll take
a little bit of something
off each one of them.
Like Arsene Wenger--
spending nine years with him.
The freedom that he gives to the
players, his calmness, the fact
that this office is always
open for conversation, the way
that he's managed
to turn your head
around was really interesting.
Because Arsene--
you can say, OK, I'm
going to go to his office.
I'm going to tell him
that he was wrong.
You come back from his office
and you say, no, he was right.
He was really good on
turning and changing people
and players' minds.
This is something that I
find really interesting.
The fact that I spent
time with Mourinho,
where he was really strict
and with a really clear idea
about what he wants,
what he expects.
The information he was
given to the players--
that was really, really good.
I had Capello when I was 18
years old, when I was in Italy.
The way that he's
managing the group,
his tactical knowledge--
I've been really lucky.
So I learned a little
bit off of all of them.
But I think what is
important and if I really
want to be successful,
I have to know who I am.
I have to coach with my
personality and my philosophy.
If not-- if I try to be
Mourinho, Wenger, or Capello--
I'm not going to have any
chance to be successful.
JON JAKLITSCH: If we were
to ask your players today
to describe you as a manager,
and you said, I need to be me--
who are you as a manager?
PATRICK VIEIRA: That's
a really good question.
I think I am in the process
of learning who I am
because I am a young manager.
I spent two years
with a developing
squad and a developing squad is
at a different level from where
I am now-- because for
two years I was working
with the development squad.
And the developing
squad, winning or losing,
it doesn't matter.
What is important is to
develop players for the future.
And now I went to
a different world
where it is all about winning
and winning with style.
And I'm facing some situations
that I've never been in before.
And I'm in a certain
situation that I still
learn a lot about myself--
how to deal with a situation,
how to deal when we're losing
7-0 against the other team.
That type of situation
makes me learn about myself,
about how to deal with the
pressure because being a player
and being a coach is
completely different.
When I was a player, I was
concentrated about myself.
Players, in general,
we are egoistic
and we're always
thinking about ourselves.
I was preparing myself
during the week to be fit,
and to be mentally prepared,
and tactically prepared
for the game on the weekend.
And when you are a
coach, you become last.
You're thinking
about other people
before thinking about yourself.
So the transition is
completely different.
And the transition
was difficult.
So I'm in the situation
that I'm still
learning about myself and
knowing about myself, about who
I am, as a coach.
JON JAKLITSCH: Great.
You also mentioned
that you wanted
to bring your philosophy
towards the game-- kind of how
you think about strategy.
Can you tell us how you
think about strategy
towards the game?
And how you try to implement
that at New York City FC.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yes.
I have a clear philosophy
and a clear way
that I want to play in
position or out of position.
We're watching the
opposition team.
And then the way
we are preparing
ourselves is that
we analyze what
is the strength and the
weakness of the opposition team.
And during the week,
we work on that.
Normally, what we
are doing is we
spent two days regarding
how can we really hurt them
and two days about
how we can control
the strength of the
opposition team--
what to expect from
the opposition team.
And then we get the time
where we focus on ourselves,
about how can we improve from
one game to the other game.
All the training that
we are doing is filmed.
And then we do a lot of
videos before training,
after training.
Players do an individual meeting
with the coaches regarding
the position because
what we find out
is that some players are
really learning faster
and the message is more clear
when they are on the field.
And for other ones, it's
when they are in the room.
And the game is really tactical.
So that means it's
important for us
to really spend time on
the tactical side of it
because games can be
losing and winning
in a tactical
aspect of the game.
JON JAKLITSCH: Sure.
And turning now to New York
City FC and kind of this season,
obviously, you've set very
high expectations for the team,
as any good manager should
going into the season.
Can you tell us a
little bit about how
you think the has team has
fared versus those expectations?
And maybe anything that
needs to change for the team,
moving forward?
PATRICK VIEIRA: There's
been some ups and downs
during the season.
There's a lot of frustration
because I believe
that we play some
really good football
and we're not getting
awarded with the way we've
been playing at the moment.
We create a lot of chances when
we played, we're scoring goals,
but I strongly believe that
we should score more goals.
We should have more
points than what
we're having at the moment.
But on the other
side of the game,
the fact is we're conceding
a lot of goals as well.
How to find the
balance is something
that we really need to work on.
To be honest, I'm really
pleased with the way
we're playing at the moment,
but, on the other side,
I'm not really happy
with the points
that we're having at the moment.
We should have more points
than we're having now.
There's still a lot
of work to be done.
At the same time, we
have to be patient
because the team is
only two years old,
the club is only two years.
But in our world,
there's a lot of pressure
and we don't give too much
time to work and to develop
ourselves.
So I need to figure it
out as soon as possible.
But I'm happy with
the way that we
try to play football
because that's
what's really important for
me and is really important
for the club.
We want to win.
And we want to win playing
the right football.
JON JAKLITSCH: Got it.
Now let's turn a little
bit to the MLS, in general.
I know you're a bit
newer to the MLS.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yes.
JON JAKLITSCH: Tell us--
PATRICK VIEIRA: And it's
completely different.
JON JAKLITSCH:
Very, very different.
And that was going
to be my question.
What do you think the hardest
part about winning in the MLS
is, say, versus the
European leagues
where you played in the past?
PATRICK VIEIRA: I think is
really different because we're
talking about the MLS who had
only 20 years of existence.
It's really difficult
to compare the MLS
with the European league.
But I believe that
they will get there
because-- when you look at the
number of games that have been
shown on TV now, you look
at the number of fans
that you have at
the stadium, you
look at the number
of kids who are
playing football-- the game
is going up in the country.
But, of course,
they are far away
from what they have, at
the movement, in Europe.
It's really difficult to
because-- as a coach, what
I find really difficult
is that in Europe, you
play your first game,
at a professional level,
between 16, 17 to 19 years old.
And in the US, a young
player played his first game,
at a professional
level, between 20 to 22.
And that is really late.
So I believe that the
grassroots football
has to improve a lot in the US.
The number of hours that young
players spend on the field
has to be much more than what
it is now because there's
a massive difference of hours
of practice between Europe
and in the US.
JON JAKLITSCH: And why
do you think that is?
So let's turn a little bit,
maybe, to the culture of sports
in the US versus in Europe.
What do you think the
biggest difference is?
Obviously, soccer is
not the number one sport
in the US versus Europe.
Do you think it's just the
games aren't on TV as much?
As you mentioned, there's
not as much grassroots.
PATRICK VIEIRA: I think it's
a little bit of everything.
When you're going
to college here,
when you look at the
college competition
here-- the football in college--
you're training twice a week
and you play four
months of competition.
And this is between
16, 17 to 22.
And this is a crucial period
of your development in Europe.
And that period--
this is where you
make it or you don't
make it, in Europe.
And to develop those
players, in the US,
and that age gap is too late.
And they will need
more coaches, they
will need more
grassroots training,
they will need more
facilities as well.
But it will take another 20
to 30 years to be better.
But I think they are doing
the right stuff at the moment
because everywhere we're going,
there are fans at the stadium,
there are kids who
are playing football.
And I think the future looks
bright for the US National
Team.
JON JAKLITSCH: That's great.
And everyone in
the audience, we're
going to open it up for
Q&A in a few minutes.
So if you have a question,
feel free to line up
along the podium.
So you mentioned 20 to
30 years down the road.
That seems like a long ways off.
PATRICK VIEIRA: It
is a long way off.
JON JAKLITSCH: It's a
long ways off for us here.
Do you think it'll take
that long for the MLS,
say, to be on par with some
of the European leagues?
Or do you think that
will come sooner?
What is it going to
take, essentially?
PATRICK VIEIRA: I think
it will take time.
It will take time because the
league is completely different.
I'll just give you an example--
we played in Portland.
From New York to Portland
is seven hours-- six hours
and a half, seven hours flight.
When you're in
Europe, six, seven
hours is the period you're
taking to go to holiday.
So you're not traveling six,
seven hours to play football.
So the traveling is a
massive problem in the MLS.
And you have to deal with it.
So you have some
problems in the US
that you don't have in Europe.
So they just need to
find the right way
to deal with those issues and
I think things will be OK.
But I'm not worried
at all about it
because when you look at
where soccer was 10 years ago
and where it is now,
in the next 10 years,
it will be even in
a different level.
JON JAKLITSCH: Yeah.
And then even in
the last five years,
I've noticed a huge
difference in the number
of people who are interested
in the World Cup, MLS.
You can definitely see it now.
PATRICK VIEIRA: It
would be fantastic.
And what they really need
is the US to do well.
If they do well and if
they have one player who
can be an example or a role
model for the young players,
that would be even better.
JON JAKLITSCH: What do
you classify as doing well?
I'm curious because we did
fairly well in the last World
Cup-- as the US making it
out of the group of death,
making it to the round of 16.
Do you think winning the finals?
What do you classify--
PATRICK VIEIRA: You have to win.
JON JAKLITSCH: You have to win.
This is a tough guy over here.
PATRICK VIEIRA: You have to win.
This is the society
where we are living.
You need to win.
You need to win, you need
to have a role model,
like basketball.
Basketball carries one of the
best players at the moment
and he's an example
for the young players.
And they always need
this kind of person
that can lead the sport.
And this is what they don't
even find yet in football.
If they find that person
who can be the role model
and be one of the best
players in the world,
then you will have
more young players
who will play
soccer because they
will want to be that player.
For us, growing up in France--
and for the young players
in France-- it's really easy
because we had Michel Platini
before, and then we had Zinedine
Zidane, now you have Pogba.
In France, we always managed
to have one player who
is part of the best
players in the world
and he was a good role
model for the young players.
And I think, in
the US, if you have
that, that will help to develop
the game in the country.
JON JAKLITSCH: Hopefully,
that's sooner than
20 to 30 years, but we'll see.
PATRICK VIEIRA: I hope so, too.
JON JAKLITSCH: Anyway,
that's going to conclude
the informal chat portion.
By the way, we wanted
to give you a Google
shirt for coming today.
Anyway, here you go.
PATRICK VIEIRA: I was
hoping for a free lunch.
JON JAKLITSCH:
Tough guy, again.
PATRICK VIEIRA:
Thank you so much.
JON JAKLITSCH: Of course.
And we'll start with
the Q&A session,
if you want to go first?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is this on?
Oh, great.
Thanks, Patrick, for being here.
I'm a lifelong Arsenal fan,
so it's great to have you.
My question is around
how football has changed
and how that would
change the way you think
about things going forward.
So If we could take a 18
year old Patrick Vieira
and put him into a team
today, working for a manager
today-- because you know Arsene
Wenger and Arsenal are very
different now as they were
10, 20 years ago-- where
would you want to play?
And who would you
want to play for?
And why is that?
PATRICK VIEIRA: The game
changed and I don't think
the game changed for good.
I think, honestly, it
became a little bit more
difficult because I believe
that the gap is going up
between fans and players.
And one of the reasons being is
that young players, I believe,
today are earning
too much, too early
with not showing too much.
And this is what the
problem is in football.
But I don't think
it's just in football,
I think it's a problem that
we are facing in our society.
Young players or a young
person wants the job
with doing nothing.
And this is a problem
of the society.
And this is what we
have to deal with.
And I think clubs--
we have a massive part
to play because
to earn something,
you need to deserve it,
you need to work for it.
And we need to change that.
If not, I believe that it
will get worse and worse.
And if I'm 18
again and if I have
to choose a manager that
I would like to play for,
I would say Pep Guardiola
because of the vision
that he had and the way
that his team is playing.
I think I would enjoy it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thank you.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Thank you.
JON JAKLITSCH: Let's take
a question from over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned earlier
the greatest players
you played with.
And, obviously, the level of
top quality is unbelievable.
I have two questions
that relate to that.
One, how do you think is the
best way for those players
to come here?
At they start or in the
middle of their career,
as opposed to what we've
seen over the course
of the past decade, where
the top players come here
towards the end of their career?
And two, how has your
transition been here,
given that you've played
on the highest of levels
and you've come here,
where it's probably not
on that same level?
PATRICK VIEIRA: You're
asking me that question.
You want to be in trouble
with the [INAUDIBLE]
we have in our team?
JON JAKLITSCH: Tough question.
PATRICK VIEIRA: That's
a tough question.
No, but I think you have--
I'll try to be a diplomat here.
AUDIENCE: Please don't.
PATRICK VIEIRA:
You have stepped--
you understand what I mean?
You have, step by step--
I think when they created
the MLS, what was really
important for the people
from the MLS is, how
can we show to the world
that we want to build a
really successful league?
And I believe that
the first step
was to bring players
with a big name
because you want to make
the world aware of what
we're trying to do here.
And you're going to
a different step.
And I think, in our football
club, it was the same.
We bring players who were
marginally well known,
but we bring players to
our football club who
won everything in
Europe, but they still
have desire to compete,
to be successful,
and to win something
with the club.
And I think, in the
next four, five years,
the MLS has to move
to a different level.
A different level is to
bring young, talented players
from Europe.
And I think Giovinco
is a perfect example.
But before you bring in
these young talented players
from Europe, you have to be
established as one of the best
leagues in the world.
And I don't think
the MLS is there yet.
And to bring these young players
to the US is really difficult.
Because when you are 21 years
old, you've played in Europe
and you're still hoping to
play in your national team.
And the best way to go
to the national team
is to play for
the European team.
And I think, as a nation here--
US-- we are not there yet.
So it's really
difficult to convince
because we don't have
all the tools yet
to change the mind of
a 21 year old player
to come to play in the US.
And that will happen, I believe,
in the next five to 10 years.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JON JAKLITSCH: Great.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yeah.
I hope I answered your question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks so much.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Thank you.
JON JAKLITSCH: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a huge fan, and I
really respect your work,
and I think you're
an amazing player.
So you had a very
interesting point
when you mentioned
the team in 1998,
where you said it was
representing the society.
And you really sent
a clear message,
saying that, hey,
even though we come
from different backgrounds, we
are here together, as a team.
So I guess my first
question is, do you
think this is still true
with the current French team?
Like for instance, Benzema
not being chosen and attacking
the coach for that.
PATRICK VIEIRA: You are trouble.
You are trouble.
AUDIENCE: So what do you
think is the secret recipe
to make a team, like to
have all the players as one?
And my last question
is, who do you think
is going to win the Euro Cup?
PATRICK VIEIRA:
I think I'm going
to start by answering
the second question.
I hope France will
win the Euros.
And I think they will
have a massive chance
to win it because of the
young, talented player
they have in the team.
And, of course, in all
the big competitions,
if you want to have a chance
of winning the competition,
your best player has to be
at the peak of the game.
So for France to win the Euros,
Pogba has to be at his best,
Griezmann has to be at his
best, the goalkeeper, Lloris,
has to be at his best,
and all the other players
have to perform as well.
But you are not going
to win a competition
if your best players are
not at the best level.
So hopefully, they
will be at their best,
so they can have a chance
of winning the Euros.
Answering your
first question-- I
don't think-- knowing
Didier Deschamps the way
that I know him,
he didn't pick up
Benzema or Ben Arfa because
there wasn't a space for them
in the national team.
And I strongly believe
that it's based on what
they are doing on the field.
And then we can all agree,
saying, yeah, but he's good,
he's not good.
But what is important
for the people
to understand is that
you are choosing people
and you are making the team
not just for what's going on
on the field, you're
making the team
regarding, as well, how
they're going to live together
and how they're going to
conduct themselves together.
And Didier Deschamps was
the captain of the '98
and was the captain of
the European Championship.
And he managed, at that period,
to bring everybody together
in the French National Team.
So he knows what it takes
to win a competition.
And if he makes that decision,
that is the best for the team
because you're not just
playing-- you live together.
And sometimes you have to make
a tough decision not just based
on the football aspect
of it, but the outside
is as important as what's
going on on the field.
JON JAKLITSCH: Thanks.
For you.
AUDIENCE: So as an athlete, when
you're struggling on the pitch,
or when you were
struggling on the pitch,
or when your players
are now struggling
and they make a mistake
or two mistakes, what do
you do, or teach to do,
so that they successfully
forget about it, and they're
able to focus on the next play,
and able to perform, mid-match,
so that they can still perform
well, even after
making a few mistakes
and stay mentally tough?
PATRICK VIEIRA: The
best coach I had
for that was Arsene
Wenger because I remember,
when I was at Arsenal,
I made a few mistakes.
One of the actions
coming in my mind,
it was when we were playing
the semifinal of the FA
Cup against United
where I missed the pass,
and the guy got the ball,
played it forward to Giggs,
and Giggs scored.
Before that game, I was
making a few mistakes
and we could see the
goal straight away.
But what was really
important-- and the message
was from Arsene to me-- was
keep doing what you believe
is right for the game.
And that, for me,
was really important
because it wasn't about-- it
was a technical mistake that I
made, but the ideas
behind it were right.
And that message, for
me, was really strong
because that gave
me confidence that I
was doing the right thing.
So in training, of course,
I needed to practice more
about this range of passes.
And that really
gave me confidence
to try it again and try it
again until I became successful
on that.
And that is a message that I've
tried to send to the players--
mistakes are part of the game.
Mistakes are part of the game.
And I want them to
try to do it, if this
is what the game was required,
if that was the right play
to do.
And, of course, what we're
doing in New York is,
regarding the
period of the week,
we're doing some
individual training.
And we have five or six coaches.
And we always take three,
four players and we
make them work on their
weakness or their strength--
it's dependent on the week.
And we make them practice,
and practice, and practice.
Because I strongly believe
the more you practice,
the less mistakes you're making.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So thank you for being here.
And you named the best
players you played with.
You said Zidane,
you said Bergkamp.
And you said that
the best players
had this a spark or something
that brought the team together.
And Bergkamp, and
Zidane, and you
have all become
managers as well.
Is that the same talent there?
PATRICK VIEIRA: Being a manager?
AUDIENCE: Being a manager.
So the talent to be a manager
and the talent of having that
spark on the field that
makes everyone else
look good-- because
it seems like that's
your job as the manager--
make everyone else look good.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And that's
what Zidane did.
And that's what Bergkamp did.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yeah.
Being a manager is
completely different.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PATRICK VIEIRA: And it's not
because you were a fantastic
player that you will
be a fantastic manager.
It is a completely
different world
because when I was
working with the EDS--
it was between the
ages of 16 and 19.
And they had some
pictures of me playing
and they knew what I'd
achieve on the field.
And it was good, but,
at the same time,
it was really bad because
the first contact with them,
they were really looking
at me with big eyes.
And I was telling
them, jump 10 times.
They would jump 10 times.
But what was really important
for me is the message that I
was going to send to them
because the message has
to be clear, it
has to be simple,
and it has to be consistent.
Because being a good
player and being
a coach straight away
after, it gives you
a little bit of credibility.
And the credibility can be one
week, 10 weeks, two months.
And then after, when players
lose a little bit of confidence
on the manager or on the coach,
you having been a player or not
a player-- it doesn't
make any difference.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Thank you.
JON JAKLITSCH: So
unfortunately, we
have to wrap up
soon, but let's just
take one last question maybe?
PATRICK VIEIRA: You can't do it
when he's wearing a City shirt.
JON JAKLITSCH: Oh.
PATRICK VIEIRA: You
didn't do it to him
when he was wearing
the New York shirt.
JON JAKLITSCH: We did.
We gave one Red Bull fan--
AUDIENCE: Thank
you, Patrick, really
appreciate it as somebody who
was an early, early, NYC FC
member.
Thank you for being
here at Google.
PATRICK VIEIRA:
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: We welcome
you very much.
Thank you for being at NYC FC.
I actually had two
questions, but I'm
going to get to
the main question.
What do you think
about the state
of our defense in the last
three games, minus the big game,
of course.
PATRICK VIEIRA: That should
be our last question.
You should have cut it before.
JON JAKLITSCH: You
asked for this side?
AUDIENCE: As a fan, actually,
it does matter to all of us.
There's some similarities
from last season.
Our defence has
been a little leaky.
You mentioned it came
down to a little mistakes.
Last game-- we were
there yesterday.
But what do you think?
What can we do to
improve our defense?
We have some new
signings this season.
They're doing well.
I like them, personally,
but what do you think?
PATRICK VIEIRA: To be honest,
about the new signing,
we didn't really start
talking about it,
but, obviously, the window
will be open in July.
And with Claudio, our
sporting director,
we're going to start talking
about what is the plan
and what can we do
to improve the team.
Because, obviously,
when we are facing
the situation where we are,
we need to improve the team.
And what is really difficult
to convince the fans
and the people of is that, when
you look at our game from last
night-- after a game like that,
you or the majority of the fans
think that the massive
problem we had was in defence.
Yes, we conceded the goal,
but you guys are just
looking at the goal we
conceded, but you're not
looking at the number of
chances that we created.
AUDIENCE: But we did.
I don't mean that
we did not convert.
It was--
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yeah.
But if we scored all the
chances that we created,
especially in the
first half-- 3-0.
The game is over.
AUDIENCE: True.
PATRICK VIEIRA:
And then we're not
going to concede the goals that
we conceded in the second half.
Yes, we have to
improve defensively
because we're giving
too many goals away,
but, for me, I believe that
what is important in football
is always to create
more than we concede.
And when you look at
the game yesterday,
we created more chances
than we conceded.
So if even we scored half
of the chances we created,
we would be winning the game.
You will be happy,
I will be happy.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
PATRICK VIEIRA: You
understand what I mean?
So yes, we have to
improve defensively,
but, for me, the main
concern I have at the moment
is that we need to score
more of the chances
that we are creating.
And when we concede
the goals, it's
not just about the back
four because I believe
that it's about the team,
it's about the unit,
it's about the 11
players on the field.
And we have to make it
a little bit more easy
for the back four.
So that means the
back four are not
going to be exposed so much.
So the front players in
front of the back four
have to do better work.
The front players have
to do better work.
So it's teamwork, more than
individual or just a unit.
But yes, we have to improve
our defensive record.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Thank you.
JON JAKLITSCH:
Should we do one?
I know you've been waiting.
Let's just-- if you
can do it quick.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Hi, Patrick.
PATRICK VIEIRA: How are you?
AUDIENCE: I'm also
French and I was
6 when you won the World Cup,
so it's great to see you here.
PATRICK VIEIRA:
Thank you very much.
[INAUDIBLE], by the way.
AUDIENCE: In '98, the
World Cup was in France,
France was having
some difficulties,
there was lots of talent.
And the situation is not
that far away from today--
the Euro Cup is going
to be in France,
I think France is also having
some problems right now,
there is also lots of talent.
Maybe there's not as much
experience with the players,
like Pogba or Griezmann.
Do you see many similarities
to the team in '98?
Or what are the main
differences that you see today?
PATRICK VIEIRA:
I think, when you
look at the social
situation in France,
I will say this is quite
the same type of situation
that we were in '98
that we are facing now.
This is why I really hope the
French team will win the Euros,
so we can send a strong
message to the country.
France is all about diversity.
And our diversity is a
strength of the country.
What I feel really confused
and really frustrated
is about politicians
using football and getting
involved in what's happening
on and off the field.
| do understand this is their
responsibility because they
are politicians,
but, in the same way,
football people should
deal with the problems
that football are facing.
And I don't think
that politics should
be involved in any kind
of football decision.
And this is why football
is above everything.
And I hope that they will give
a really good representation
of the game, and they will
send a strong message,
and a positive message.
Because I believe that football
can have a massive impact
in the world and, especially,
in France as well.
AUDIENCE: Well,
let's hope they win.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Thank you.
We can take the last question.
He was waiting.
AUDIENCE: Merci.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Am I
going to get a free lunch?
AUDIENCE: So my
question is going
to bring you back to '95, '96.
I'm a AC Milan supporter.
PATRICK VIEIRA: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
to know, were you
there at the wrong time
and the wrong place?
And what was the key learning
of your experience in AC Milan?
PATRICK VIEIRA: '95, '96,
when I was at AC Milan?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PATRICK VIEIRA: It was
a positive experience.
I left Cannes and
I went to AC Milan.
I was 18 years old.
And at 18 years
old-- at that time,
you were only allowed to
have three foreign players
in the team.
And when I signed for AC
Milan, I was the number six,
so I was behind Boban,
Savicevic, Desailly, Weah,
Paulo Futre, and
then it was myself.
So to have the chance to play,
four of them has to be sick.
So it was really
difficult because they
were at the peak of the game.
AC Milan was at the peak
of the game at the time.
But, for me, this
is where I learned
how to be a professional
because I opened my eyes.
And I looked at how they
conducted themselves,
how they were
training in the week
to be fit, and prepared
mentally and physically
to play the game.
And that was a fantastic school
for me because, at that time,
the Italian league was
the best in the world.
And it was really competitive.
All the best players in the
world were playing in Italy.
So to spend only
one year in Italy
helped me to be the
player that I was.
So that was a
fantastic experience.
JON JAKLITSCH: Great.
And that's a wrap, everyone.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Thank you
JON JAKLITSCH: Thank you
again so much, Patrick.
Let's get you your
free lunch now.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Yeah.
But before-- I was hoping
for the free lunch,
that's why I brought you a gift.
JON JAKLITSCH: Oh.
PATRICK VIEIRA: Don't worry,
it's not a Red Bulls shirt.
JON JAKLITSCH: So nice of you.
PATRICK VIEIRA: So it's just
to show the appreciation
and to say thank you very
much for having us here.
We just brought you a shirt
signed from our [INAUDIBLE].
JON JAKLITSCH: This is great.
The other side.
That's amazing.
Thank you very much
for coming again.
I appreciate it.